[Musique]
celle de l' alerte verte c'est une
archive présidentielle de 74 avec un
candidat pas comme les autres
[Musique]
et vous savez ce qu'il va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera à lundi je vous dis au revoir
et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes amis
rené dumont le candidat écolo qui n'a
pas été prise au sérieux du nord pas
même par les grands partis de gauche non
bien sûr mais moi j'avais 14 ans je me
souviens vraiment de cette semaine on
avait une télé noir et blanc enfin je me
souviens très bien de cette scène et et
pour moi ça a été le début aussi d'une
prise de conscience je suis pas rentré
je suis pas devenu écolo
à ce moment là je me suis pas intéressé
aux formations verte qui commençait à a
voilà à exister dans le pays mais en
revanche il y avait du côté du ps eu du
côté de cette deuxième gauche beaucoup
de femmes et d'hommes je pense aussi à
huguette bouchardeau je pense d'une
certaine façon à michel rocard aussi qui
portait déjà ces questions d'écologie
alors ce n'était pas tellement sur l'eau
c'est vrai que lui rené dumont a été le
premier à le prendre sur cet angle là la
gauche et y compris cette deuxième
gauche le prenait plutôt sous l'angle du
développement et moi j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser vraiment à ce moment là
aussi à la politique et aux idées
sociales socialistes et écologistes mais
ça a été pour moi vraiment un
oui une alerte quelque chose qui à ce
moment là m'a ouvert vraiment sur cette
question de l'écologie et je m'en
souviens encore j'avais 14 ans
[Musique]